here's a treasury secretary janet yellen
and i love showing clips of her because
uh a few months back she had hope that
we weren't going into recession i'd like
someone who's doing something about it
in charge of the treasury but she had
hope which it's always good to have hope
you gotta have hope right i do expect
inflation to remain high although i very
much hope that it will be coming down
now i've seen shawshank redemption hope
is good hope is a special thing we all
know it very important dev hope
otherwise you're not going to get out of
that jail that you've been improperly
imprisoned for decades you gotta have
hope she has hope by the way someone
yesterday at the end of the show
remember they said that she looks like
uh the lemonhead guy from the candy we
checked it after she does
so i want you to take when you're done
watching the show today i want you to
take a picture of janet yellen and then
pull up the uh lemonhead guy
her head because her head is kind of
like this and like this very lemon heady
anyway here's yellen there is a ton of
data coming out this week it's probably
a a a fun week for an economist because
we're gonna have consumer confidence
survey the second quarter gdp numbers we
got the inflation numbers for june
which is the indicator what's the number
you're most
focused on that will give you a better
indication of where this economy is
headed
well i look at all the data and
gdp will be closely watched
a common definition of recession is two
negative quarters of gdp growth or at
least that's something that's been true
in past recessions when we've seen that
there has usually been a recession and
many economists
expect second quarter gdp to be negative
first quarter gdp was negative so we
could see that happen and that will be
closely watched but i do want to
emphasize
what a recession really means is a
broad-based contraction in the economy
and even if that number is negative we
are not in a recession now and um i i
would you know warn that we should be um
not not characterizing that as a result
i understand that but you're splitting
hairs i mean if the technical definition
is two quarters of contraction you're
saying that's not a recession that's not
to take
no that's not the technical definition
there's a an organization called the
national bureau of economic research
that looks at a broad range of data in
deciding whether or not there is a
recession and
most of the data that they look at right
now continues to be strong i i will be
would be amazed if the nbar would
declare this period to be a recession
even if it happens to have two quarters
of negative growth we've got a very
strong labor market um when you're
creating uh almost 400 000 jobs a month
that is not a recession yes it is the
technical definition and that's exactly
what you said right before that the
technical definition if the gross
domestic product goes down basically for
two quarters in a row it's a recession
so she basically was like if the gross
domestic product goes down two quarters
of a row it's a recession but this thing
which is go we know is going down back
to back to criminal it's not gonna
happen
what i mean you know when chuck todd has
to ask you a follow-up question you
really stepped in it
here's the elderly man pretending to be
president talking about how we're not
going into recession even though
everyone knows we're going into a
recession mr president we're getting gdp
numbers on thursday how worried should
americans be
that we could be in a recession
we're not going to be in a recession uh
in my view uh
we uh the employment rate is still one
of the lowest we've had in history it's
in the 3.6 area uh we still find
ourselves with people investing
uh my my hope is we go from this rapid
growth to steady growth and uh so see
we'll see some coming down but i don't
think we're going to uh god willing i
don't think we're going to see recession
there's nothing more comforting than an
elderly man with a horrible camera angle
sitting back like this choking on his
own phlegm scratching his head while he
tells you that we're not going into a
recession which if you saw that episode
of seinfeld when people lie they touch
their face and the bigger the lie is the
higher up on their head that they
scratch or touch uh and he said i hope
we're not going to
god these people are terrible